you're almost the narrator of this
season what's that like I feel older I'm
like oh my god I don't like a grandma
I'm dressed like a grandma today it's
just everything is not how I planned
[Music]
Asia O'Hare I we are in the thick of
season 10 of RuPaul you know it's it has
its ups and downs
hey hey you got something to say to me
you hit like a girl too bad you don't
look like one Paul's drag race star Asia
O'Hara ready to bounce back after a less
than stellar snatch game performance if
the match continues been a very humbling
experience
always room for growth wrap salutely yes
being in drag race competing what
surprised you most about what surprise
to me moat most about the entire process
is you know I have built my career on
the preparation like last yeah I know
see for growth the stuff is falling off
it's running away from me literally the
biggest thing is like there's no way to
prepare for it expect the unexpected in
all absolutes of absolutely uh got to
talk about the Hat seen around the world
was that inspired by the idea and the
lonely yes I saw that years ago and I
was like oh my god it's a dandy line and
I was like oh my god it should be you
know worked into drag at some point and
then flash forward to getting on to drag
race and you know we had to bring a hat
look I went and bought it I put it
together the the day of the challenge I
was a little afraid that we're gonna say
girl if I hit people not a half way it
works it works and hey like here
multiple uses now absolutely you
something Dallas that'll be hanging in
my living room they need to come up with
whatever the Swedish equivalent of Asia
O'Hara is and rename that laughs oh my
god please name a lamp after me IKEA I
promise I will wear it on my head
[Music]
well guys tech sisters back in the house
when you first walked into that work and
you saw all the other girls who did you
clock is that's my competition the three
people that I looked at and said that's
my competition were Monet Exchange
Monique Hart and Miss cracker and Monet
exchange she's one of those people that
you cannot help but to like there's no
way not to like her and to not like her
wigs though oh my gosh what that's a wig
get out of here you cannot like her wigs
you cannot like her costumes you can not
like those sponges but you have to like
her you surprised you but you were not
thinking this was a someone to watch out
for you know who surprised me the most
was the Vixen she tried to trick us
so she kind of was the person that had
the most growth week by week out of
anybody I have never seen such a level
of unprofessionalism as I have watching
Eureka and it baffles me that you guys
enjoy her so much I think our season has
probably the most dynamic change from
the character you see the girls present
on the runway to the character you see
the present and untuck so if I have to
tease you with anything
tune into untucked and record it because
you're gonna want to revert to it later
it's really the only time where we're
all in drag
together unsupervised by the judges so
is the one time where you can really say
you know what you feel if you had to
describe what's still to come this
season with just one word what would
your way
magic pure unadulterated magic okay I
will take magic to wrap things up
cameras have two words to you mrs. Angie
miss Vangie she is really the season 10
mascot cheerleader fangy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]